alors la première fois que je me suis
retrouvé confronté à occulte de la
compétition
c'est quand j'ai quitté la réunion à mes
18 ans je suis aller m'installer en
métropole à toulouse pour faire mes
études j'avais choisi de faire une
classe préparatoire parce que j'avais
envie de faire une grande école etc et
donc j'avais envie de découvrir la
france une nouvelle vie et je me
rappelle mon aller en cours impatiente
de rencontrer ces autres étudiants qui
comme moi avaient certainement des rêves
de grandeur est là à la place de la
coopération l'entr'aide que j'étais venu
chercher
j'ai découvert la compétition entre les
individus
la dévalorisation parce qu'ils étaient
censés être des modèles pour nous les
profs alors c'est un véritable choc avec
le recul aujourd'hui il me dit mme mais
comment un système comme ça est censé
créer des individus qui demain vont
porter des grands projets pour changer
le monde enfin franchement comment la
compétition la dévalorisation peuvent
conduire à des gens avec des grands
projets je comprends pas comment la
deuxième fois que je me suis retrouvé
confronté à ce culte de la compétition
c'est quand j'ai intégré le système de
recherche
j'ai fait un doctorat à l'université de
la réunion et là j'ai vu l'envers du
décor en fait il ya un adage dans le
système de la recherche qui dit public
aux pays riches publier ou meurs waouh
c'était un peu violent quand même en
fait quand on veut faire de la bonne
recherche il faut avoir les moyens des
moyens financiers pour pouvoir faire
venir acheter du matériel faire venir
des chercheurs dans son labo moyens
financiers que l'on peut obtenir que si
on publie dans des grandes revues à
comité de lecture comme on dit et pour
publier dans ses grandes revues et bien
il faut faire déjà de labos de recherche
donc soit on est dans le cercle soit on
en est exclu alors du coup moi je suis
pas trop étonné qu on assiste à des
fraudes scientifiques le chercheur et
pète un câble tri il invente des données
ils oublient de déclarer des conflits
d'intérêts et je lisais récemment
d'ailleurs que plus il y avait de la
compétition dans un domaine de la
recherche plus on observait de fraude
scientifique depuis 2009 moi je bosse
dans un pôle de compétitivité
je pense que c'était de trouver pour moi
ma mission me paraît vraiment essentiel
en fait je dois aider des chercheurs à
travailler avec des chefs d'entreprise
pour qu'ils montent ensemble des projets
collaboratifs innovants qui vont faire
la réunion de demain une réunion qui
sera confrontée qui est déjà confrontés
à la mondialisation qui sera confrontée
aux changements climatiques et qui a
cette impérieuse nécessité de préserver
son bien commun la réunion elle-même son
histoire son peuple sa culture ses six à
ses remparts et en fait je vais vous
dire quelque chose
cette mission aller parce qu'elle est
vraiment compliqué en fait depuis que
j'y travaille je n'ai pas rencontré
beaucoup de chefs d'entreprise qui soit
serein heureux leur quotidien c'est quoi
charles compétition handicap structurel
pour qu'elles aient faut lutter et ça
vraiment ça me chagrine
j'arrive pas je me dis à quoi bon vivre
dans une société aussi riche aussi
technologiques ou les sciences nous
apprennent l'infiniment petit à
l'infiniment grand
si c'est pour être si malheureux demain
on aura presque une mode connecté qui
nous dira combien de temps il nous reste
à vivre et on n'est pas foutu d'être
heureux alors pour moi une partie de la
solution c'est la bienveillance avoir de
la considération pour l'autre si on
habite tous de la bienveillance les uns
pour les autres on pourrait faire de
cette terre une terre plus heureux une
terre plus juste oui parce que en fait
la bienveillance a conduit au bonheur en
fait quand je fais preuve de
bienveillance envers quelqu'un je lui
donne de la considération
cette considération va créer chez lui
un sentiment de valeur je vaux quelque
chose ce sentiment
celle estime de soi estime de soi qu'il
permet ensuite une confiance en lui-même
et du coup d'entreprendre et à force
d'entreprendre
on va renforcer l'estimé de soi et à la
fin la personne peut à son tour faire
preuve de bienveillance jeu on connaît
tous ce jeu de billes la comprend la
billon l'éloignent comme ça on la lâche
et elle va taper dans la suivante comme
ça elle va donner son énergie à la
suivante la suivante jusqu'à la dernière
elle s'éloigne
et puis elle revient en arrière et puis
s'il n'y avait pas de frottement dans
l'air on aurait un mouvement perpétuel
eh bien imaginez vous votre
bienveillance comme ceux cette première
impulsion que vous donneriez à quelqu'un
pour elles à transmettre aux suivants
qui pourraient la transmettre à suivre
et 1,6 à reviendrai vers vous je pense
sincèrement que vivre cette boucle de
bienveillance c'est ça le bonheur
alors j'entends certains qu'ils vont
tout si tu me dire oui ni la
bienveillance ok pourquoi pas mais
franchement la sélection naturelle c'est
plutôt la compétition on dit pas l'homme
est un loup pour l'homme et à sage enfin
moi ça me chagrine meetic quoi ça
voudrait dire l'égoïsme c'est spontané
naturel il est là en nous et puis la
bienveillance altruisme ce serait
quelque chose de construit toi et ça
pour moi c'est pas possible
et donc j'ai commencé à lire un peu la
littérature scientifique et là j'ai
découvert quelque chose que je veux
partager avec vous c'est que si
aujourd'hui la théorie pour expliquer
pourquoi
l'homo sapiens a pris le pas sur os
moderne vers thalys sait comment sapiens
avait su développer des réseaux il avait
su échanger ses savoir faire et ses
compétences
et c'est comme ça qu'il a pu surpasser
et survivre et exister aujourd'hui à
travers nous alors comme monnaie interne
à l'iss était bien le plus fort et le
plus costaud donc on est un peu loin de
l'image seul le plus fort sur vie et
puis en fait cette bienveillance
elle existe un aimant nous imaginez-vous
là ce soir vous recevez un collègue à
manger et cassin vert qu'est ce vous
allez lui dire
attaquer c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
ça c'est cette bienveillance qu'on a en
fait en chacun de nous donc oui la
bienveillance et naturel on l'a en
chacun de nous ok d'accord je veux bien
l'admettre mais concrètement on fait
comment alors pour apprendre à devenir
bienveillant moi c'est d'abord passer
par une prise de conscience je suis
maman de deux enfants trois ans 18 mois
et je vous avoue c'est pas facile tous
les jours c'est même assez compliqué en
fait j'étais un peu tiraillé comme ça
entre deux visions de l'éducation une
vision qui étaient dictées par la
société qui dit ouais obéissance avant
tout et puis une vision qui me disaient
non mais l'enfance est un individu il a
besoin de considération il faut
l'accepter et j'étais perdue entre ces
deux visions alors je décide d'aller
suivre des ateliers de parentalité
bienveillante et là j'ai compris que je
pouvais changer et surtout j'ai appris
deux choses importantes qui permettent
d'être bienveillant la première c'est
d'apprendre à gérer ses émotions et la
deuxième c'est d'apprendre les coudes de
l'autre alors gérer ses émotions c'est
pas simple parce que personne ne nous
l'a appris d'ailleurs vu qu'on est dans
l'université je dirais superbe on nous
apprend j'ai pas moins la trigonométrie
mais la gestion des émotions serait
temps de commencer et par exemple en
fait gérer ses émotions sa consistance à
consiste d'abord à connaître la palette
des émotions et un chercheur qui dit il
est urgent d'alphabétiser les émotions
comme on apprend le faire le bleu le
rouge aux enfants effectivement la
colère la tristesse la peur la joie et
toutes les nuances
il faut apprendre ce que c'est deuxième
étape reconnaître là tout de suite
qu'est ce qui se passe en nous qu'est-ce
qui lé l'émotion qui nous traversent
je vais vous donner enfin je vous invite
à faire cet exemple vous passez une très
mauvaise journée au bureau ça s'est pas
bien passée que les collectes
enfin on connaît tous à rentrer à la
maison pas content on va voir notre
conjoint on lui raconter tout et là il
nous sort quoi il ya pire dans la vie
là qu'est ce qui se passe
le vent de ce nous le cueille bad for
android le manque d'air je suis en train
de mettre en colère je me mets en colère
parce que je n'ai pas eu de la
considération de la personne et je
l'attendais cette considération
légitimer ce que je ressens je suis en
train de me mettre en colère laisse moi
de le mettre en colère et donc voilà
apprendre à gérer ce les émotions c'est
ça la reconnaître l'admettent
l'accueillir du matin c'est salins
qu'est ce qui se passe on se laisse
traverser et s'est passé premières
compétences à acquérir et la deuxième
celle écoute alors apprendre à écouter
l'autre c'est aussi un travail c'est une
personne nous l'apprend écouter en fait
c'est regarder la personne dans les yeux
être là à 100% et part en train de
pianoter l'ordinateur la télé je ne sais
quoi c'est vraiment l'accompagner en
écoutant ce qu'elle a va nous raconter
va nous raconter un espèce de mélange de
faits de ressentis etc et nous en fait
en écoutant attentivement on va l'aider
à mettre des mots sur ce qu'elle ressent
et ses salles écoute de l'autre donc de
compétences essentielles pour être
bienveillant soi même la gestion de ses
émotions et l'écoutent de l'autre bon ok
je vais peut-être je peux changer moi
même pourquoi pas mais et la société et
comment changer la société dans tout ça
alors moi je dis qu'il ya plusieurs
endroits il faut agir tout d'abord chez
l'enfant
naturellement à la maison en particulier
mois avant avant tout mes lectures
toutes mes ateliers payants en fait
j'avais pas du tout créer un
environnement bienveillant la maison
lavabo trop où je mettais mes enfants
dans un lit à barreaux comme dans une
prison pouvait pas aller à table sortir
de table comme ils voulaient 20,0
autonomie par contre mais bibelots mes
livres mes bijoux tout ce qu'il fallait
pas toucher portée de main forcément je
passais mon temps et bien non et à
m'énerver
en fait j'avais pas très d'environnement
bienveillant et à force de lecture un
jeu je vous invite à lire un peu ce que
s'écrit maria montessori par exemple
je me suis rendu compte que il faut
créer cette ambiance bienveillante à la
maison et donc chez moi tout a changé
avec mon conjoint on a revu
l'organisation pour créer ce sentiment
de bienveillance une autre enfant j'ai
nos deux enfants alors ça se passe à la
maison puis ça se passe à l'école il ya
de nombreuses expérimentations menées
alors y en a une en gennevilliers par
céline alvarez et puis il y en a aussi à
la réunion où en fait on crée un
environnement de réussite pour l'enfant
dans la classe ça passe par un travail
et un suivi individualisé et du matériel
adapté aux capacités physiques et
cognitives de l'enfant et quand on fait
ça et bien un enfant et développe
spontanément de la bienveillance et de
l'entr'aide pour les autres créativité
et estime de soi
je trouve ça puisse en moi un dernier
volet sur lequel il faut développer la
bienveillance et dans nos relations
professionnelles moi aujourd'hui quand
je reçois un chercheur quand je reçois
un chef d'entreprise je les accueille
avec cette bienveillance je leur sourit
je leur demande comment ils vont et
j'écoute ce qu'il me dise est en fait si
on veut travailler ensemble après on est
obligés d'accueillir l'état dans lequel
ils sont au préalable et ce qui me fait
penser que j'ai raison de travailler sur
ce secteur sur ce domaine plus tôt c'est
que dans de plus en plus de magazines
économiques
on peut lire que des propos sur la
bienveillance en entreprise et ce qui a
été montré c'est que lorsqu'on développe
la bienveillance dans ses relations
professionnelles
on augmente la coopération entre les
salariés puis avec ses clients ses
partenaires
cette coopération qui conduit à une
meilleure performance de l'entreprise
alors vous l'aurez compris pour moi la
bienveillance est devenue une
philosophie de vie
je l'appliqué à la maison avec mes
enfants mon conjoint avec ma famille mes
amis mes collègues et j'en vois
réellement les bénéfices chaque jour
alors je vous encourage à vous aussi
d'entrer dans cette dans ce mouvement
perpétuel et de devenir à votre tour et
de développer la bienveillance autour de
vous et là j'aimerais vous inviter tous
à vous lever
avec moi de vous mettre debout
dans mon coeur bat fort fort même
de prendre une très grande inspiration
de ressentir ce qui se passe en vous de
souffle et de sourires et de regarder
vos voisins de droite et de gauche avec
bienveillance
merci